today for our daily cancellation we turn
to the actress Carrie Washington who has
published an ex published an excerpt
from her upcoming Memoir in Time
Magazine and as you've uh noticed the
bar for Memoirs has been severely
lowered in recent years it used to be
that there were two basic requirements
for writing a memoir first you have to
have led an incredibly interesting life
to write a memoir and second you have to
be a great writer Memoirs are things
that exist for fascinating writers
who've lived fascinating lives and there
are very few people who fall into either
category and few are still who fall into
both categories that's the point it's a
very rare person who is worthy of a
memoir but that's all changed and in
fact it's been flipped completely on its
head and now in most cases Memoirs are
written only by the worst writers who
who have lived the most boring lives
they're written by someone like Carrie
Washington a run-of-the-mill actress who
starred in a bunch of mediocre Network
TV shows um how can she justify a memoir
what can she possibly have to say about
her life that's worthy of a memoir what
important experiences has she had well
in her Time Magazine piece she tells us
about one uh she had an abortion so she
may not have done anything interesting
or incredibly instructive with her life
or constructive but she did kill her
baby and uh that story really needs to
be told she thinks so reading out says
in my late 20s I made the difficult to
very private decision to have an
abortion about a decade later I played a
character that was the first woman to be
shown undergoing an abortion procedure
on network television as women it is our
right to choose what happens to our
bodies our lives and our futures it's
also up to us to decide when how and
with whom we share our stories the
reality is that abortion is a very real
and normal part of women's lives I share
the story of my abortion procedure here
because our right to make choices about
our bodies and our lives is under attack
both culturally and legislatively this
is my story I am one of many and we will
not be
silenced now one thing um you notice
about liberal women is that they never
shut up but they're always claiming that
they're being silenced especially when
it comes to their abortion stories every
time a woman come like this comes out
with her The Saga of her abortion she
always has this elaborate melodramatic
windup where she insists that it's it's
finally time it's finally time for women
to talk about their abortions except
that women have been talking about their
abortions for decades okay we've heard
this story over and over and over again
in fact before we read any more of
Carrie Washington's personal and private
abortion story we already know
everything it will say because is always
the same script that's because evil is
not very Innovative it tends to repeat
itself right it's the banality of evil
which is why every woman who has ever
bragged about killing her child has
sounded exactly like every other woman
who has bragged about killing her child
so we don't need to keep reading uh but
we will continuing it was January in New
York City I'll never forget how cold it
was that morning I was grateful for the
need of additional layers not only to
keep me warm but also to hide and Cocoon
myself away from the reality of the
procedure I was about to
undergo um let's uh stop there for a
moment Carrie you say you wanted to hide
from the reality of the procedure you
were about to
undergo why why would you need to hide
from the reality of the procedure if
abortion is a legitimate medical
procedure and if it's not in fact the
murder of a human child then why do you
need to hide from its reality you know
if I were to ever write a memoir about
my experience getting surgery on my torn
Achilles in 2019 which would at least be
as interesting as your Memoir I would
never say that I wanted to hide from the
reality of the procedure okay I would
never open it like that with some it was
cold outside it was dark cocooned myself
from the reality of my Ailes procedure I
would never say that uh now I may have
gotten a little nervous about getting
surgery in general but there there was
nothing about the reality of the
procedure that I found upsetting or
distressing the reality is that they
were going to fix something that was
broken it's a good thing I was happy
they were doing it
ultimately um you were not happy you
were hiding from the reality why what is
it about abortion that made you want to
hide if if you actually were to explore
that question in an honest and
introspective way then your abortion
story might have a chance to be the
first of its kind to have any value
whatsoever but of course you don't
explore that question you just you say I
wanted to from the
reality never explaining why what is it
about the reality that you want to hide
from what's so upsetting about
it never explain you skip right over it
and we move on to this continuing I sat
in the waiting room and completed the
paperwork with false information a
madeup name a pretend address a
non-existent email only the phone number
was my own should the office need to
reach me in case of an
emergency let me stop there again
um in what other context can you go in
for a surgical procedure and get away
with providing in completely false
information they never asked for your ID
they never verified anything about your
identity they never even verified your
age so we're constantly told about the
invisible hurdles that women have to
jump over to obtain abortions but this
makes it clear that the hurdles are
significantly lower than they are for
any actually legitimate medical
procedure moving on it says when the
nurse called my false name I followed
her into a small office she proceeded to
ask me requirements that she was U
questions that she was required to asked
by the state to help me make sure that
this was the right choice for me and my
family quote unquote my body felt hot
with shame as a teen I performed with a
health education theater company and i'
had spent years on the other side of a
version of that conversation asking
young people to consider their options
and weigh the consequences I was
schooled and schooled others in the ways
of prevention and the language of sexual
empowerment but in my own life I had
committed the crime that seemed
unimaginable to me back then I had let
the Heat of the Moment dictate choices
that would impact me for a lifetime why
hadn't I protected myself why hadn't I
the courage to create boundaries around
my womb why had I silenced the
preferences in the my preferences in the
name of people pleasing this all could
have been avoided if I had spoken up for
myself in that moment I wouldn't have
found myself in that office but there I
was surrendering my insides to a
surgical vacuum trying to repair the
damage borne of my silence and need to
be
loved few points here
um first of all for anyone listening to
this
uh you may have experienced challenges
in your life you may have suffered in
many ways but look on the bright side at
least you were never subjected to
performances by Carrie Washington's
health education theater company so
however bad you think it it it may be in
your life it could be worse there are
people apparently years ago who were
sitting in audiences watching a health
education Theater Company starring
Carrie Washington second notice the
passive tone that Carrie adopts here she
chose to have sex outside of marriage at
a time when she felt she was unprepared
to have children and it led to
predictable results in fact her sexual
experience had the same result that
literally billions and billions of other
sexual experiences have had a man in a
woman had sex and they made a baby it is
a story as old as Humanity itself it has
played out tens of billions of times
across the world and through history yet
Carrie Washington presents herself as
perplexed I sex with a man I became
pregnant I how could this have happened
how could this have
happened well I I can tell you how it
happened I mean you're the one who was
in a health education theater company I
think you should probably
know but it's not really her fault she
informs us she she was just people
pleasing by having sex with the guy she
did it for her her for his sake really
her only mistake was not establishing
boundaries which is a not so subtle way
of essentially putting all the blame on
the man because she only had sex for his
sake this this was about pleasing him he
was crossing boundaries the sex was
something that was happening to her and
if she's to blame for anything it's for
not speaking up for
herself right reading a little more she
says later as I lay on the medical bed
with my feet and stirups the doctor
described her plans for the termination
the instrument she would be using and
what it might feel like at different
stages along the way I had been to
several gical uh gynecological
appointments through through the years
but never one so transactional today I'd
come to this office office for a
particular result and required a
definitive outcome when I left I would
have I would be a changed woman without
the burden of new life but perhaps with
a bit more time to understand and Define
my own as the doctor opened my cervix
and inserted the thin vacuum tube the
nurse looked down at me smiled and very
gently said do you know who you look
like I think she was trying to comfort
me to tell me that even though uh This
Moment was incredibly difficult she
could see the beauty in me could see
that I reminded her of a movie star she
said my real name I could hear it under
the the muffled sound of the water in
which I was drowning Carrie Washington
it was my name but the version she was
calling out had nothing to do with me
and so in that moment I didn't know who
I
was okay
um we probably read enough at this point
two other quick points though first as
predicted the writing here is just
absolutely
atrocious I could hear it under the
muffled sound of the water in which I
was drowning never mind that again
abortion is supposedly a legitimate and
positive medical procedure and yet she
Compares it to Drowning okay you would
never describe any other medical
procedure that way but that aside this
is just tremendously awful writing she
is laboring to make the whole experience
sound profound and poetic and beautiful
but she is she is she's finds herself
hamstrung by the fact that she is a
shallow midwit actress who has never had
a profound thought in her entire life
and the result is a sentence like I
could hear it under the muffled sound
sound of the water in which I was
drowning which is equal parts clunky and
cliched it sounds like something you'd
read in a 10th grader's creative writing
assignment and by the way just this is a
pet peeve but okay you can actually end
a sentence with a preposition nobody in
real life would ever say the phrase the
water in which I was
drowning you didn't rescue me from the
drowning you would you would just say
the water I was drowning in
that's what you would say now your
public school teacher told you that
there's some Ironclad grammar rule
forbidding you from ever ending a
sentence with a preposition but that was
just one of the many things your public
school teacher lied to you about okay
you can end a sentence with a
preposition someone if you see someone
with with a earbuds in you don't have to
ask
them to what music are you
listening what are you listening
to you don't have to speak like like
Yoda okay that's not the correct grammar
uh that's not that's incorrect grammar
well it's fall which uh means cozy
nights in with my family thanks to my
friends at Tommy John my loungewear for
a night in has the perfect blend of
comfort and breathability their
loungewear has a level of softness like
I've never felt before their incredibly
soft loungewear is designed to envelop
you in a world of pure luxury when you
wear it Tommy John you're so much more
comfortable than uh than that you can do
everything better even their underwear
has dozens of comfort Innovations like
breathable lightweight moisture wicking
fabric with four times the stretch of
competing brands that you can keep you 7
degrees cooler than cotton every
purchase is backed by Tommy John's best
PA you'll ever weere or it's free
guarantee you get 20% off your first
order right now at tommy.com Walsh
that's 20% off at Tommy john.com
Walsh see site for
details it's no secret that we are all
loving the genu Cell Dark Spot Corrector
here it's making everyone around me have
faces I can stand to look at just barely
you might be asking what does this
product even do well if uh if you have
sunspots dark spots uh discoloration dry
skin whatever it is the genell Dark Spot
Corrector will help these blemishes
disappear in front of your very eyes
Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio I was just
talking to her and she said my
appearance has improved so much since
using genus cell on my face I love all
my genu cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but this sale is ending very
soon so you got to take advantage now of
J cell's most popular package which
includes the Dark Spot Corrector this
package also includes uh the GL the
classic genus cell bags and puffiness
treatment for immediate effects you'll
get all those products for almost 70%
off jell is so confident in their
products that you can try them for
yourself completely risk-free if you
don't see results in one day you'll get
your money back it's simple go to
jus.com Walsh and start looking years
even decades younger say hello to the
best skin you've ever had at
genucell.com Walsh that's genucell.com
Walsh more more importantly we have this
sentence where she says when I left I'd
be a changed woman without the burden of
new life but perhaps with a bit more
time to understand and Define my own and
that's the whole story right there I
mean that that's that's the part that
really matters because this is what
abortion is in in the vast majority of
instances Carrie Washington was not a
poor desperate woman getting an abortion
because she felt she had no choice now
it still would not have been Justified
even in that case but that is not the
case here she simply just didn't want to
deal with a baby she didn't feel like
having a baby so she's killing it she
even acknowledges that the Life in Her
womb is in fact life but it's a life
that burdens her inconveniences her
interferes with her
lifestyle is she killing her child so
that she doesn't end up homeless or or
you know starve to death which still
would not be a Justified reason for
killing your child because nothing could
ever justify killing a child
nothing but no that's not even why she's
doing it in her words she she just wants
to have more time to understand and
Define her own
life so she is willfully and admittedly
destroying human life for the most
frivolous reason imaginable she's
killing her own child and all that she
can offer to defend that decision is
some meaningless selfa actualization
jargon in other words she is simply a
terrible human being that's the real
moral of the
story it's the one thing we learn from
her otherwise pointless and dull Memoir
and it's why Terry Washington is today
cancelled if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed